and it's the italian game so we actually
saw a battle in the world championship
match when jan had to win he was in a
must win situation in this opening and
uh that means a lot of pieces on the
board a lot of tension we actually
mentioned this opening yesterday right
guys it's just full of life full of rich
complex uh kind of nuances for later in
the game magnus meanwhile pushing a pawn
on the side of the board and jan looking
off to the side just trying to work out
what he had planned and uh okay the
the black bishop retreats very early on
this is exactly what magnus did in the
world championship match against janna
and uh in that game we criticized diane
for maybe taking a step back with the
white knight on that last move but this
time he goes forward with the white
knight so the game has diverted away
from that world championship match and
white trying to break forward in the
center at least trying to occupy the
center with pawns black however castled
and
look at that black dark squared bishop
what a journey it's been on already now
blocked by its own pawns but magnus will
try and rectify that
over the next few times black is rock
solid but white is more active for now
yeah a very complex position these i
mean there's lots of maneuvering that
needs to be done uh but it is a very
strange position of the black bishops i
mean they're they're next to each other
and the the black the one of the black
squares looks rather pathetic at the
moment i mean it is tucked away there
but i think it's the potential in
magnus's position that you have to watch
out for um if he can free that bishop up
then uh he's gonna be okay but i mean
just at the moment from from my eyes at
least
it looks very nice for yan uh but this
must still be the world champ
preparation well guess what okay so
there has been one game in my database
played and it was played in 2022 and the
player of the white pieces was sergey
karyakin
second and the player of the black
pieces was jordan van forest guess who's
second
magnus carlson second battle of the
seconds and what was the result uh saga
karakin one
interesting just over a month ago in
vikanze
and a very dramatic game there okay will
we see the paths diverge from that game
to black knight stepping back white pawn
now
moving forward we're still on paul we're
still on
i remember watching that game and
thinking okay black's position looks
solid but not much fun to play
still some work to be done uh to just
get black's pieces out from their
starting squares from their starting
rank and white's last pawn push has also
created a nice hole for the white knight
to step back to
and uh yeah maybe we can jump into the
position just to show some of the ideas
for both sides and it's all about these
pawns for white i would love to gain
even more space and maybe step this guy
forward potentially even capture it in
the center of the board but black says
no he's just gonna park both of his
knights on this king side they're gonna
act as defenders and later maybe much
forward to try and attack as well and
i'm expecting maybe the white bishop to
come out i don't think white wants to
shut down the center yet if you shut the
center down too soon we might see a
kickback begin
the white knight forced to retreat and
then black's bishop suddenly becoming
active on this diagonal so i think white
will just develop his pieces maintain
the tension
what do we think guys in this current
position
who do we prefer and also is this still
the game between karjakin and von forest
yes it's still very much the game yeah
it seems like this is often uh magnus's
strategy that he's willing to take these
positions which are probably a little
bit worse right i mean a really small
bit worse and if it was me playing or
like i don't know like a number of other
people you just get in trouble but uh
you know when it's magnus playing he's
very happy to to take these positions
and just equalize at some point and very
confident them
here's the new here's the new move the
capture of the pawn okay after that
this is uh the players are on their own
i'm surprised because
in a position like this black has less
space black's pieces are cramped not
doing much exchanging is against the
nature of the position when you have
more space it just frees up black's
position that being said as you guys
mentioned magnus just loves this pawn
structure a rock-solid structure in the
center so after a trade and a trade of
knights as well we see white pushing
forward trying to clamp down on the
position and the knight finally kicked
back
but who does this favor to me i don't
like what napoleon is doing because
black has an easy plan out of bringing
his bishop out maybe this bishop will
come to the side attack this pawn in
conjunction with the knight as well and
this pawn looks a bit weak i don't see
white's pieces really activating quickly
enough to cause black any trouble
so okay right now still slightly more
space for white but can he utilize it
that's the question magnus very very
solid next move he's going to bring his
bishop out he's going to connect his
rooks and healthy enough for black for
now all right well we were talking about
the tour badges and
nfts we're talking about and if you want
a
free
um
nft from uh the tour collection then if
you go to chesschamps.io and subscribe
to the newsletter
you can actually get a free nft which is
very cool is it christmas so much free
spine oh yeah
free stuff you're paying for it david
i just want to record it tomorrow when i
pick up my free drinks
i just want to sit back you know just
just
you know
have david bring some grapes as well
yeah yeah
we'll just be reclining i'll feed you
something
yeah i'll just be the waiter i'll take
it easy
yeah i know that magnus has an nft right
from last season's tour yeah and uh the
winner and this one will get that nft
trophy that you see in the bottom of the
screen and
one nft trophy is also available for
auction for the highest bidder so head
into chess shops dot io to
uh make your bid for that trophy and i
have to say oh young switched his cup is
one thing i have to say and the other
thing is that magnus looks super like
into this position leaning forwards
very focused yeah and that's
body language we didn't really see from
him in the brilliant and the prelims
stage it looked like he was just lacking
energy following his
covet
infection and yeah it looks like he's
back feeling healthy feeling focused and
that's shown today in his play and
meanwhile both sides have played very
quickly up to this point almost moved
20.
ivanka do you think this is still
preparation from napoli potentially he's
diverted from that game you mentioned
but look at the clock he's gained time
from when he started we're already at
move 19.
i think this is definitely a preparation
because he played that pawn push uh
taking some space there on the left side
of the board you pay that very quickly
and so he certainly maybe it might not
be exactly theory but he's aware of the
plans
and uh yeah magnus just sitting
and trying to figure out how exactly
he's going to develop his pieces yeah
this pawn structure arises quite often
from the king's indian defense uh very
often from the king's india defense and
it all depends on whether black is able
to trade off pieces before white gets
organized if white gets organized maybe
relocates the white knight round to
maybe the c4 square so in front of it
it has some targets there are some
outposts potentially for the white
knight
and black star square bishop i mentioned
maybe it will try and attack white's
fire advanced pawn but then again
that will just be defended and black
star square bishop maybe the front piece
uh the problem child in this position
for magnus certainly seems a bit harder
for black to play um if you look at weak
squares and black's moved the bishop to
at least cover the the big weakness
there which is the b6 square
if if white can white's going to try to
maybe get a knight into that square um
i again i i
i if magnus is going to play an opening
like this he's got to expect to get a
position like this right because
you're maybe very slightly worse because
you've got some weaker squares a little
bit less space but you're incredibly
solid and um you know it's very hard to
break the position down um i'd always
like to be white though in this type of
structure because it's very you
shouldn't really lose this unless you do
something outrageous and you can just
try to improve your pieces and come into
the squares
and he's just slowly improving yan uh
with this last move and maybe the a
maybe the a5 pawn is going to be weak
later on as well um the the black pawn
on the side of the board um potentially
so it looks very comfortable for yan
when a draw is an okay result you draw
day one but you've got that chance to
push for a win and playing with the
white pieces that's the kind of position
you want right yeah
risk-free
kind of way to push and one maneuver
that white might try is to for example
if black just waits and doesn't do too
much bring the knight to the side of the
board if black just continues to wait
maybe relocate the knight back and into
this square and then you can kind of
peer at these two outposts just check
out that maybe pawn on the side of the
board you mentioned simon the pawn in
the center and i don't think black ever
wants to trade off a bishop for one of
the knights because the two bishops
might become very strong later in the
game obviously you have to prepare this
not exactly in this move order but just
one idea for later
and uh just checking out the selfies
quite interesting how some of you are
telling us some stories some of you are
watching from uruguay some of you on
dinner dates with your wife big hello to
you all and i have a question from rina
rina of kernier it's quite interesting
actually are chess players better
decision takers in general outside of
chess interesting no
[Laughter]
i would say knowing chess players
probably the opposite actually yeah i
mean yeah i'm with you david just um
it's like it's like that saying oh chess
players are really intelligent you know
because they play chess and everyone
thinks that generally chess players are
much more intelligent than normal people
i say normal people but people who don't
play chess why tell everyone simon
absolute load of rubbish i think you
know so maybe some of them of course you
know but um in general i don't think
that's true you know so what do you
think do you think i don't know do you
think chess players are more intelligent
than non-chess players i think chess
players in general i think the the
average iq for chess players is higher
than the normal uh public
i think it's a big myth i i think anyone
can be a chess player and we're all kind
of quite normal but uh i think the thing
is chess players are very they tend to
be very confident especially the higher
up in ratings you go and so they sound
very clever
and
but one thing i do think chess really
helps you with um
chess really helps you with i do think
it's good with decision taking but not
necessarily in the taking part but in
assessing all the consequences we are
very good at sitting there and go what
happens in option a l b and it's we take
a very considered planned approach there
yeah the problem is life doesn't really
work like that often you see all the
options you know that you could do all
these different things
but then you become indecisive i know
that well i know myself but also a lot
of chess players they procrastinate
because they know
okay i could do this but then this could
happen a could happen b could happen c
could happen d could happen oh it's too
complicated and then they don't take
decisions at all so yeah actually i
think the stronger the chess player the
less likely they are to make big big
life decisions ah unless given a push i
once heard uh i once overheard a
conversation between two grand masters
who are a couple and they spent well he
spent
10 minutes agonizing whether he should
have the room key or whether his wife
should have the room key and i can't you
know at the end i felt like intervening
okay
i will have the room key
enough
well one thing we do know about decision
making that air things is teaching us is
that you should never make a decision
after a very long meeting in a room
because air quality will be bad so you
need to get some fresh air and then make
the decision yeah i'll make the decision
early in the meeting and lots of
decisions being made on the board as we
see the moves fly in but not too much
has changed we see
white has centralized his rooks now
dropping back his bishop allowing one
trade of rooks i'm surprised he's rushed
with that
but then again maybe there was nothing
else to do and magnus will try and get
all the rooks off the board we just see
some maneuvering if all the rooks
disappear
magnus is slightly closer
to equality and the black pieces will no
longer be fighting for the same squares
black was cramped for space and that's
less of an issue now i'm a little bit
worried about black's
a pawn though yeah that's the one
right yeah i mean if white can just uh
move the queen up one square and then
put the knight into this hole
um
i'm not sure how black's gonna defend
defend that pawn in the long run uh
that's that's the one yeah the one
target as you say that that is uh in
black's position here yeah this pawn i
mean it's a bit of a similar case to the
other game right if you could kind of
just put it back on its start square
maybe black's just equal maybe black's
doing okay but uh yeah right now it's
it's defended by its bishop and this
plan you highlighted simon trying to
find a good way to make it happen uh for
example if we step our rook forward one
square just just uh for example we see a
trade here if black again doesn't do too
much then the white knight will step
forward this is what you're highlighting
right just cutting
severing the connection between the
bishop and the spawn and now this pawn
attacked by the white queen and only one
way to actually defend it that's to
trade off and most likely this would
backfire on black
because this pawn's still under fire and
white has the bishop pair now this pawn
as well very close to promotion
interesting decision here david because
you can go for that pawn but actually uh
yan's uh deciding to go for another pawn
in the position so yeah really
interesting brought his rook across i
guess he just doesn't want to allow a
trade and yes black has access to the
open file now but what's he going to do
with it no squares uh no entry squares
in the white half every square is
covered by one of white's bishops
now the knight coming back maybe just
scared of your idea at some point simon
the knight jumping in yeah covering yeah
i'm not sure jan's going to rush with
this pawn push i think he just wants to
keep the pieces on but
what else could he do uh maybe he could
trade a set of bishops maybe he could
drop drop this knight back bring it
around this way
just a different avenue
still pleasant for white right yeah i
think so even if you go push the a pawn
and then the b pawn and then you can you
can certainly just slowly try to
encroach on black's position here
yeah baby steps um but black is solid so
it's it's
you know
heating up slowly i must admit i really
like your plan david of uh retreating
the knight and then relocating it
to the c4 square because from there that
night is very powerful now obviously you
have to look after the white sea pawn on
c5 but once you have that covered
then you can maybe get another small
advantage that maybe black is obliged to
capture that knight and then you have
the bishop pair and then you have the
potential to open up the bee line so
there's like two little
two little things that you can get
excited about yeah i think we can
combine the plants in a way because if
black just waits again for example the
white knight can't really jump forward
yet because of this capture um so maybe
now we go to simon's plan push these
forward first push these pawns and then
plant the white knight on this really
nice square and lots of plans for white
but just putting them together in the
right order that is what jan is trying
to do and meanwhile black is a bit stuck
white can play moves such as pushing the
pawn forward such as retreating the
knight he can play those things at his
leisure
and it's not clear entirely what black
does i mean this bishop is stuck this
knight is on inside your defensive
square just behind it a bit stuck as
well i don't think black's ever going to
initiate play on this side of the board
on the king side because
white is just too solid over there it's
very symmetrical on the right half of
the board so
yeah play will switch over to this left
side and if anyone's better there it is
white it's the end upon issue well if we
do have a winner in this game then that
player will be the winner of the first
match in the final and be up by one
point before the second and final match
tomorrow and uh
i guess it's still early dates in this
game but is this a game that both of
them can win
i think it's more likely white will win
it feels like black's just on the
defensive just trying to hold the line
just trying to
stay solid but
i mean
look at it the more lightweight position
yeah maybe just a very clever opening
choice that um jan has prepared you know
before because he probably realizes he's
got the chances to win and he shouldn't
lose this position
which is what you want with the white
pieces against magnus incidentally i i
did see a tweet earlier on um that uh
peter lecker who's also commenting on
another channel tanya sajdev
they
he actually said that at uh
they were very very disappointed
uh in the opening in that uh world
championship game at the end that's uh
that game 11 that then that sent upon me
actually retreated the night everyone
was was betting that he would play the
night forward in fact that's what they
had prepared oh and napoleon she didn't
play it
i remember the position you mean there
in um it was a move eleven so the nights
you know the knight came up and uh
attacked the bishop right okay
it was yeah white's night earlier
jumping forward to the b5 square rather
than retreating towards uh right yes
yeah yeah okay yeah
this game yeah could have happened in
the world championship we could have had
this position in the world champion
basically this is the kind of thing
which could have changed the world
championships actually i mean like uh
yeah certainly and when you make a
mistake like that you forget your theory
and then everyone comes and tells you
off afterwards like why didn't you do it
isn't it because it means like even
these guys who are playing for the world
championships and they'd be preparing it
and they forget their move or move nine
or something yeah it's like they're
immortal yeah
you know they are actually human beings
and it can happen to anyone so it's
quite
quite yeah it's quite nice to hear out
of the way yeah so it gives us all hope
of uh you know if we make mistakes it's
normal so yeah but don't you find that
every time you make a mistake you tend
to remember
you tend to remember afterwards oh yeah
i made that mistake here so therefore
immediately afterwards or
even even even a long time afterwards i
remember once um so i was playing some
blitz games online and then i lost quite
badly in one of my favorite openings and
then i was like
why did i lose so badly here and i
actually went and i analyzed my game and
then it stuck with me like okay
you you you needed to do this just as
you had analyzed in 2007
and i was like oh okay yeah i need to do
that and then it came in 2015 and i
remembered because of this mistake so i
think mistakes are good to make yeah
preparation and also maybe good in in
real life as well so that next time you
find yourself in that situation yep you
remember
is that why you often uh when they do
prepare um and i did see magnus from his
training camp they would talk about some
openings and he would play blitz games
with his seconds
is that to to basically make mistakes
and and remember easier yeah i think
it's exactly what juventus said and it
also goes back to what we were talking
about earlier today about memory uh if
you play it on the board if you discuss
it with your opponent afterwards it's
more likely to stick in your mind uh if
you just look at it on a computer screen
if you just tap an arrow just going okay
memorize memorize memorize it won't stay
it's like
preparing for exams basically it's the
same thing you have to be active with
your revision um you can't just be lazy
and just
assume that it will sink in yeah
okay meanwhile a couple of moves on the
board simon
yeah this plan you mentioned pushing the
pawn forward he didn't even prepare it
as white i yeah i'm a little bit
surprised because um white's pawn
structure is now worse than black's pawn
structure and that's quite dangerous to
do that against magnus because if things
backfire you know you could be in a
worse ending
but it also is quite logical because
your rook is attacking the pawn i mean
uh you're opening up your rook you're
playing with your pieces though now uh
more than your pawns um i mean it's
quite interesting you talk about blitz
and playing blitz to improve positions
and they had that big thing in poker
really when poker went online
um
the quality improved like so drastically
because if you used to play poker you
could only play i know let's say 50
hands in a day because you have to wait
for the dealer when you're playing
online you're playing 50 hands in like
five minutes so the amount of
information you're gathering is like is
exponentially higher so you're getting
so much more information you're learning
from that information at such a higher
rate and it's it's the same with blitz
chess right you can play blitz at such a
higher higher you know get more games in
and absorb more information and i think
you can see all the all the young grand
masters do that now don't they just
practice practice online bullet chess
and they get all the information a lot
quicker so it's probably why another
reason has been a big
rise in the strength of players i guess
so that's why they're becoming
grandmasters younger and younger at 12
years old now because at the age of 12
they probably played more games than
maybe 30 years ago players had played by
the time they were 25 so
yeah just more kind of
more games to analyze as well a bigger
sample size of games where you can learn
from your mistakes and study and okay
meanwhile jan getting up looking
confident jan was shaking his head kind
of not in a bad way just confused about
magnus's last move and to be honest i'm
surprised that magnus moved so quickly
if we dive into the position um just to
catch up with what has happened over the
last few turns we see a really dramatic
moment that i was about to say didn't
happen on the board but it has now just
happened on the board white stepped
forward with this pawn we thought he
would prepare this and after a trade i
was expecting black to pick up this pawn
and maybe push it forward utilizing the
fact that on passant here would drop a
rook still complicated but if white
takes this pawn as if it just moved once
then black could zoom forward and
capture the white rook still very
complicated after pawn takes bishop for
example in the rook blocking maybe jan
was expecting this magnus just not going
for this but he's gone for it in a
different way
so if we catch up with the current
position the black rook just slid across
to defend this pawn now after the white
queen sidestepped we see this black pawn
push on passant
looking like it's just a very strong
move and it was played by januponishi
but magnus's idea is to bring his bishop
out allowing on passon allowing this
strong pass pawn to survive white to
pawn up but look at this the white rook
is actually trapped
these two black bishops actually cover
all of the escape squares for this rook
so it's really complicated right now i'm
expecting uh yan well there's two
options basically this rook is doomed
you either step forward with your pawn
and allow the capture and then take back
with your pawn you're actually down a
material of rook for a bishop but you
have this strong pawn as compensation or
the alternative is to just sidestep with
the rook also giving it up but getting a
very strong bishop in return and looking
towards the enemy king now so magnus is
about to go material up but the
evaluation bar still in the middle means
that the computer thinks white has great
compensation here decision time which
bishop do you want
um i think i would choose the light
squared bishop i'm going first
yeah i'd probably you know instinctively
say the same because um in
those kind of positions there's a great
attacking piece towards your opponent's
king so
i yeah they both look nicer because if
you do it the other way you get the the
c5 square yeah um which is really
tempting you know you can put a piece on
that one so either way they look good
right i mean uh i i think i take white
in in both both positions actually so
this move or this one are the two ones
we're expecting and
yeah as you guys say you can give up
your rook but okay he chooses to give
his rook up for this bishop and uh after
the pawn push we see a trade i don't
think we'll see the queen uh take back
this bishop it feels like white wants to
keep the queen on the board there we go
white's queen is potentially a great
piece on this diagonal and maybe along
this file as well this line looks like a
really nice sacrifice i mean uh
because that pawn
is two squares away from queening
and
i don't think you can ever eliminate
that pawn i mean
how how bad is this for black actually i
mean i i the computer says that black's
better which i find surprising yeah um
because that pawn just seems so strong
here uh so advanced up the board so
always gonna have some tactical ideas
around just queening it at some point
so i i like and also it's kind of
position yand likes playing right he
likes having the initiative um he's he's
got the initiative and he's got a bit of
pressure here yeah this is the type of
position it might say roughly 0.0 but
i mean one wrong slip and it's going to
shoot off in white's favor yeah doubt
we'll see it go off in the other
direction it feels like magnus is the
one who has to be most accurate and
maybe this is also the type of position
as as the computer thinks more as the
horizon gets uh further and further it
will realize this is a long-term
advantage for white this just having
this pawn here and it does balance out
the material deficit
yeah wow
yeah because i'm i'm not even sure what
black's plan is as well again it's going
back to the idea who's got the easier
plan
and white can improve his queen try to
get the c5 square so uh c6 square so
yeah i can bring the bishop out and push
the pawn even further at some point
plenty of ideas as you mentioned you can
jump into this square at some point as
well
i i don't see what black does there's no
at all um
can can black play for perhaps
eliminating that dangerous past pawn and
returning the material and just saying
let's get the queen back and then yeah
yeah actually maybe
it's kind of not that nice and it's not
aggressive but maybe it's necessary but
maybe you go queen d2 yeah against that
one and then try to come into to the
central square
d6
and not win but just annoy the opponent
yeah just but if i could come right into
d6 and uh
um
you know maybe you can go rook a8 but
rook a8 looks very risky yeah it's scary
times i mean even if the rook moves you
just step back with the knight or yeah
uh at the minimum actually maybe you can
even jump forward with the knight yeah
yeah right yeah the tactics seem to work
out in white's favor all due to this
pawn being strong for example knight x
porn let's see some trades just to show
an example and the white bishop's also
very very good bishop takes knight and
white would be winning two bishops
stronger than the rook i think i
i'm actually thinking like this is
really bad for black as they are
positioned i i it feels like there might
be a bet coming on here oh
i'm not brave enough
i know they say third time lucky but
charm you sure do you want to check your
wallet first and see if you can uh
so
call the bank first to see how much
i will give you draw odds with black you
can have a draw or win from magnus the
world champion
and i'm gonna i'm gonna go for a yan win
with white simon you're very brave what
do we play what are we playing for this
i still wanna i still want you to tell
me one drink so maybe just one drink
i don't know what would you like to go
for if you did take it so you are
banking on a white win and i would get
you get the draw and a black win it's
like a slight bargain of the century
yeah but i'm not a gambler and you're an
expert and oh i don't know
not a gambling i meant like
just clearly
take it david take it
okay
one beer
so if i well one one drink
so if i win this is
i'm going to be looking for any small
benefit for black i love white's
position that's why i'm streaming i'm a
bit stressed about this but this
position seems nice okay queen b6 just
putting the black queen on a slightly
better square and bishop too calm why
not the move you like there simon oh i
mean
simon's going to need a win for yong in
this game to win that bet i don't like
bishop e2 it seems slack win good
prediction that's why you were brave
simon well i did i mean i didn't expect
him to play it out but
okay
um it was a calm move by white but yeah
just a bit slower it seemed very slow
yeah i mean i don't know what else to
play but
okay
okay so white's knight under fire from
this black rook that night most likely
just has to move i don't like the way
the bar's going that way
what's happening with that bar is it
going the wrong way um yeah i'm i'm just
staring at that bar trying to use my
telekinesis to make it go in black
direction now so what okay i mean
it wasn't it wasn't clear what white
should have played instead of bishop b2
but bishop b2 is like what's it actually
doing yeah you're not really as well
yeah i mean you're not playing with a
purpose you you need to play of a
purpose and it's a very safe move but
you're not really worried about the
queen coming down anyway so i mean it's
just white queen feels like it could
have been improved yeah
wait once one second here i mean isn't
there an issue with
the night the white knight the white
knight i'm just looking at the board and
i'm just thinking
where's it gonna go it's only really got
one square what are some problems the
bishop now is bad on e2 because of okay
two ideas right so i mean you have to
you have to you can't move your queen
because if you move the queen to defend
the knight
then okay the pawn on b4 is hanging yeah
uh you can't jump in with your knight
forward because oops the pawn on b6
lacks protection
so
either you have to
yeah and my bishop even better than that
the bishop is hanging um okay so if you
retreat the night that's like one step
in the wrong direction now maybe the
queen drops back and you round up this
pawn
yep okay so maybe you know you can't
even do any decoys still complicated but
looking like magnus may be turning
things in his favor how does jan keep
his knight defending this pawn
maybe this pawn which we highlighted as
a strength
might not be defensible anymore
you feeling good dave i'm feeling better
i should you want to up the stakes uh
simon no
i like that the stakes are getting
higher yeah
no no no no no okay interesting move
there by pogneshi struggling to defend
his knight he decided to counter-attack
against the black queen and now he's
maybe hoping that the bishop gets traded
and black captures it with the knight
because now the white pawn i guess will
recapture and these guys as a combo are
going to be hard okay this does happen
it's taking it wow these guys are going
to be hard to break down long term then
again maybe it's just very very concrete
here maybe black can just trade the
queens
this is this is the thing that really
sharp the magnus and the you know like i
noticed a lot on their plate uh it looks
incredibly risky to take that knight but
they just have so much supreme
confidence in their calculation and
maybe he's just calculated he can just
get away with us and i know swap the
queens off or something i think he can
change up and like david highlighted
like once the queen comes off basically
all you need is the light square bishop
to to keep an eye on the past pawn or
sitting on b6
and then the rook is free to wander the
board and it's going to create a lot of
mischief that being said it's still
quite concrete white could push forward
with his pawn uh rendering the black
rook passive and now defend it with his
bishop
maybe this pawn it looks strong but the
white king can march over and deal with
it still super complicated
uh
to me it's not clear anymore i got quite
excited because i was like oh what
happens if the bishop gives herself up
yeah miss pop she's quite interesting
like this yes
but then the knight comes and sits on b6
and then yeah so black's root gets
active but it can be blocked off by the
white knight and in the current position
napolishi is thinking uh he sorry not
this position after this one black's
knight captured and does he take with
the pawn which is by far the most
natural establishing two strong
connected pawns or is he possibly
contemplating taking with the knight
look at his time as well david his time
he's got he's taken with a knife wow so
he's allowing the black rook into the
position
with a skewer
okay the bar going up in magnus's favor
but at least now this is one strong
piece and the pawn is pushing forward
whoa look at the bar wow what is what is
this trick has he just missed something
here because black surely can just jump
in with a rook
and as mentioned this is a skewer the
black rope protected by a bishop and if
the queen moves the bishop falls behind
it
what is the idea does he just want to
move his queen and then bank on this
pawn he's got to rely on the b pawn yeah
but uh the queen is looking at it and
the queen can keep a real close eye
and she can move herself back to the
square that david indicated
and
i can't say it look down yeah it's going
to take white an age to break through if
you try and swing your queen across to
try and dislodge the blockade of white
pawn then the black rook just swings
back across and the white queen can't
infiltrate she can't
uh get through that was the worst bit of
the day as soon as i played as soon as
we
let's go back to the players it's really
tense but it looks like magnus has a
winning move here by bringing his rook
in wow and he finds it yeah he played it
maybe he's just an oversight by nicolas
maybe he just forgot that the queen is
guarding the promotion square see if his
bishop was back on next to the king then
this this would be absolutely fine so
it's that it's that little bishop move
he played
instantaneously which uh which really uh
changed the position i feel it's just
really funny because it was quite a
small innocuous looking bishop move and
somehow it's had this like butterfly
effect yeah yeah why it's created all
these complications and unfortunately
they're all in magnus's favor yeah and
unfortunately for jan it's a bit of deja
vu it's similar to some of his blunders
at the world championship match where he
just took his eye off the ball for one
second and maybe mis-evaluated or saw
something that wasn't really there or
overestimated his position i like i like
some of the
i like that twitter yeah i like i like
the animals when we bring the animals
into twitter and that is one and this is
a cool looking dog from our control room
uh just uh a couple meters away from
here because i recognize bella the dog
the dog of our producer nice
taking control of this show
that is
our producer normally now bella is in
control
[Laughter]
yeah how's charlie doing simon charlie's
doing great yeah yeah he's old cat but
he's doing very well so hello to charlie
the cat another try get another pet with
a twitter account right he has got a
twitter account charlie the chess cat
so
definitely so actually white's pawn has
march forward magnus went for the
winning move taking the white bishop off
the board black is a whole rook up but
jan is arguing that his pawn that white
pawn on b7 that has just pushed is worth
a whole rook
we think it isn't the evaluation bar
thinks that pawn isn't worth the rook
but jan's still looking relatively
optimistic
and uh still some tricks in the air
white actually has a threat white's
knight wants to go to the edge of the
board to the asic square to support the
advance of that white pawn so maybe
black needs to prevent this
and how do you do that i guess by just
using the black queen as a blockage yeah
i think ivanka's just you know the move
for bringing the queen in front of the
pawn uh it looks looks pretty simple and
then are you just going to bring the
rook around to a7 and take it i mean
something like that something like that
um simple i mean
simple-ish the only thing that i can
think of that could potentially be in
the air is that maybe white has some
like captures knight takes bishop and
then the queen can dive down but
unfortunately the rook is a really
powerful long-range piece and it can
just slide to the open d-line and just
bring yourself back i i just think that
winning ideas queen b8 were okay to rook
a7 i mean
i can't
i think this is the winning move and
as simon mentions the plan is just to
bring the rook back and eliminate this
pawn uh even at the cost of a rogue as
long as you get the white knight in the
process black will have an extra bishop
and as ivanka mentions a bit of a
complicated line here but knight takes
bishop i mean if black wants to play a
safe you just take this pawn and
probably you're winning anyway but the
most ambitious is also maybe the best
take this night off and after queen
takes pawn this is a deadly threat
actually eliminating the black queen and
promoting a white pawn but uh yeah rooks
are great defenders and this rook can
just step to the side and slide back to
defend the eighth rank and even after
queen takes pawn white has three pawns
now for a rook but it's not enough the
black rook will simply step back and
eventually these pawns will drop one by
one
and long
the long way around but it is winning
okay magnus chooses a different square
for his queen so
this one just looks so natural
blockading but he drops it back one
square wow
wow what has happened the computer
thinks
just to explain white now has swung the
queen across and magnus has put his
queen on a bad square because now the
move he wants to play is to bring his
rook across hitting the white queen but
now knight takes bishop would be winning
because black's put his queen on the
wrong square there's no time to take the
white knight because the rook would fall
off and they both they both have a great
body language i mean magnus head head in
his hands and yan suddenly jumps up
what what a what a blunder he's just
careless he put his queen on the wrong
side lazarus into the future rising from
the dead you know we had written right
we hadn't written uh napomneshi off and
uh suddenly
one big mistake yeah now come back
suggested by the computer but they're
not easy actually here magnus has to go
into defensive mode he's shaking his
head he has to bring his rook back and
swing it back
the other moves are not obvious at all
giving a check doesn't help black
situation white's king will hide safely
and black's third choice move here which
is also fine putting the king on the
side that's not obvious either white has
a simple plan of bringing the queen up
and making a second queen thanks can't
stop that's really phenomenal that's
good news for your bet oh yeah
reacting he knows yeah he blundered yeah
yeah he just put his queen on a square
within range of the white knight now
knight takes bishop will always hit the
black queen
and uh yeah it's
he knows it's just careless it's
complacent maybe he thought he was just
winning instantly and he's reacting
cursing himself and yeah it's going to
be hard to come back from that though
yeah because i mean you know queen b8 is
probably just game over and you you just
realize you've blundered it's been a
long day of chess even the top players
can make mistakes and how do you recover
from that will he recover or will he
give me that third point
oh yeah
i think he'll recover i think he just
has to he's got two minutes he's got to
get it out of his system stop cursing
himself and look for the best moves yeah
two minutes so he's got two minutes he's
out of it you can see yeah that's it
he's now gone back into the
concentration mode and he's trying to
find a way how to survive and he has a
few options as david mentioned but they
all involved all of the options i think
involved bringing the black rook into
the defense and that i mean the most
obvious move to me is probably the
safest just moving that black rook
across to the left one square and
bringing it back the whole way i think
in that fashion you can give up the rook
for white's very strong pawn and
most likely secure a draw but it's just
about whether magnus coming and calming
himself down he doesn't find that yeah
okay i mean all the games have been so
much drama today yeah i mean there's
just drama drama drama it's incredible
yeah so how much
has been going on
and well that's that's that's a bit
disappointing that move so
but a good move and so that's why he's
the world champion because he can
recover from these setbacks everyone
blunders he's human as well and uh he
blunted away the win but he just took a
few minutes got it out of his system and
now finds a good defensive move now
white's queen going up to the top of the
board check is going to be blocked by
black's rook
and uh yeah white now can bring the
knight over so try and promote to a
second queen we might see a position
with three queens on the board
temporarily but black's rook will give
itself up when that pawn pushes forward
yeah and uh i was just going to say when
it comes to that resulting ending queen
and knight against queen and bishop
it's going to be napomiacci he's going
to be
grinding away maybe he'll win a pawn in
the process
the black c6 pawn might be dropping if
black isn't careful here magda's still
defending uh he's the one on the back
foot for sure
not just the momentum changing but also
some serious threats white is
threatening the black queen with his
knight and also black's rook if it goes
and takes the white queen will allow
white to replace that queen with a new
one um the white pawn protecting that
queen
it's a little bit worse for him
definitely i mean uh and i wouldn't be
able to cope with this turnaround
personally i'd be so annoyed myself i
just crumble um you have to have
extreme mental
uh
you know endurance to be able to just
handle a turn of events like that when
you know you're completely winning and
suddenly you have to defend simon okay
wow i was going to say is he going to
promote to a rook he didn't pray he
promoted a queen um okay slightly
surprised jan did it in this fashion he
was hoping that he would see a queen
exchange and then white's knight would
have come round and taken the black c6
pawn it was indefensible but magnus
finding a clever move he wants the queen
trade but on his own terms so if white
takes the queens off now the black
bishop will recapture and everything
will be protected it's hanging by a
thread for magnus but i mean that's the
kind of ending where you're a little bit
worse but if you're magnus you draw
right yeah because the knight is better
than the bishop if the queen's come off
the board it's got a lovely square in
front of the black pawn but it's not
enough to win uh because you you've only
got you don't really have any weaknesses
to attack so i think i think you're
still okay i think things are looking
all right
i i don't know i think you will be in a
pony actually who's having all the fun
and uh with that tiny porn move you know
there's kind of ghosts in the air
perhaps the white king taking a wander
yeah nice little path coming to the left
black plays copycat so it's complete
symmetry with the pawns on the right
half of the wood it just depends whose
pieces are better than knight or the
bishop should white keep the queens on
what do you guys think i think if he
wants to win he should because the
problem of any ending is that white's
pawns on the king side are also on light
squares so you've got to try to get your
king to the to the c6 pawn the other
side of the ball but then you leave all
your pawns on the same kind of square as
black's bishop and i feel that that
would always give black enough counter
play so he's playing for the win i mean
this is if you want to play for a win
you keep the queens on the board and
he's done that so bro okay i think it's
still a bravish decision to play for the
win here one thing that does worry me
actually by keeping the queens on the
board is that the white king
doesn't have a safe home you know yes it
can tuck itself in the corner but you
know it's still on an open diagonal and
if the black queen manages to find
herself on a good circuit she's going to
be cut she's going to be checking that
white king for a long long time
yeah big if though i'm not sure how the
queen gets there maybe
black will have to take uh some big
decisions in the meantime and magnus
can't have uh can't take those big
decisions with much time on his clock 35
seconds
okay incredible the bet is still in the
balance that's for sure
no it is i have to say i'm feeling a lot
more confident than i was definitely i
mean uh i
i you know knight and queen are just
tremendous at working together yeah they
combined so well i mean while black's
king a bit scared of any potential
attacks it has tucked itself away i
expect white to do the same before
ivanka's idea becomes really effective
now it's harder for the black queen to
go for those checks directly yeah and
yeah both kings super safe but the queen
and knight looking better coordinated
for now than the queen of bishop yep
yeah this one it could come down to the
clock as well yep magnus pushing pawns
harry the h1 yeah when in doubt designed
to kind of keep the white king unsafe um
that's that's the main purpose and then
again you just use up some time on the
clock really not that much that black
can do apart from no
look at magnus's face as well shaking
his head leaning back frowning yeah the
black queen is almost stuck just
defending the pawn in front of her
because you can't move the black queen
into the corner to come down i guess you
just go queen to a fight you just block
the queen and uh
you gotta be careful white queen doesn't
come in towards the backing as well as
well this is a good positional move to
stop black from playing that move and
having more chances to check with the
black queen so uh keeping the pressure
up i mean but okay what how is white
going to win this that's the question uh
i mean you can try a lot of things but
there's no obvious way if magnus just
moves his king around like he's doing
well magnus actually gave us a little
bit of a master class yesterday in the
70s he kind of said you know there's no
obvious win so you just be patient and
you just keep prodding and poking and
seeing what you can achieve
now wait for the mistake they're both
under a minute now both under a minute
so the tempo is very slow at some point
it's gonna have to go
it's gonna have to speed up because
otherwise they're just going to lose on
time so uh you know
they're playing they're playing like a
classical game here but they've got like
30 seconds left so it's like
yeah this is a real chilled out yeah it
is yeah for now believe it or not
both sides copying each other as well
pushing pawns in symmetry and now white
uh the black king came forward the white
king came forward black's king stepping
back
i think they're a winning plan that's
the question i think the problem is if
white ever tries to move his queen it
allows the black queen to come in
because at the moment the white queen is
covering some very important squares
so
where is he going
before is he going to go he can't no no
no no he's going to push but look at his
face shaking his head
he's down on the clock now as well yeah
maybe it's a good practical decision
just to escape with that draw
allow me to win the bet please yeah
what else is there okay he goes for the
win good man
we like he's been so brave today i mean
uh
every game yeah brilliant he's he's
often turned down the draw today
fighting chess index score going up and
up for both players he deserves it and
uh okay white's queen on the seventh
rank but as you mentioned this does
allow the black queen to finally step
away from the defense of her c6 pawn now
the black queen has an open line to try
and break through on maybe a diagonal
towards the white king i think if the
queen's come off then um
okay he's playing this this is
okay i feel now black should be all
right because his queen's going to dive
into the position go active lots of
perpetual checks lots of uh attacks
against g2
um i feel i mean i guess so yeah i think
black can pretty much secure the draw
now by bringing that queen active and
this is instructive you don't want to go
past if you don't want to just defend
that black pawn with your queen that
will give white time
now diving in yeah active defense always
the best if you can do it we've talked
about this before don't go passive if
you've got a choice to go active
and uh yeah black unfortunately doesn't
have the opportunity to ask for more
from the position by introducing the
bishop and oh he does
he does go for it but okay now it's
napoleon who has to force the draw and
look at him he's smiling he has to
repeat moves otherwise white is about to
get checkmated and there we go more
drama in this match but it's a draw
again and they're both shaking their
head again it's like an incredible day
chess